das ist schon etwas mysteriös astronomie
teams kennen den asteroiden 64 78 gold
schon seit mehr als 30 jahren doch erst
jetzt wird klar dass sich dieses
himmelsobjekt äußerst seltsam verhält
statt nur einen schweiz zieht der
aktiven gleich zwei schweizer hinter
sich her
aufgrund dieser merkwürdigen beobachtung
hat ihn jetzt ein us forschungsteam
genauer ins visier genommen und dabei
gab es eine weitere noch größere
überraschung die erstmalig in echtzeit
beobachtet werden konnte klicks um
science fiction die gips trägt die
spannende science - abonniert den kanal
und aktivierte glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nicht vor
herzlich willkommen dreieinhalb jahre
braucht der asteroid 64 78 gold für
einen umlauf um die sonne und sein
durchmesser beträgt etwa 3,7 kilometer
diese charakteristika sind alles andere
als ungewöhnlich und so geht dieser hast
du jetzt seit seiner entdeckung im jahr
1988 als ein ganz gewöhnlicher standard
as doch das änderte sich schlagartig im
januar diesen jahres denn die teleskope
des atlas surfer auf hawaii beobachteten
etwas äußerst merkwürdiges konkret haben
sie entdeckt dass das so ist einen
langen trümmer schweif hinter sich
herzieht wenig später stand dann sogar
fest dass es sich um insgesamt zwei
schweizer handelt und das ist wirklich
ungewöhnlich denn in der fachwelt kennt
man es bislang nur von kometen dass sie
staub spuren hinter sich her ziehen im
laufe ihrer untersuchungen konnten die
forschenden dann herausfinden dass der
astori zu den sogenannten super
schnellen rotoren gehört damit sind in
der fachsprache brocken gemeint die sich
so schnell drehen dass sie beinahe von
der zentrifugalkraft zerrissen werden
für eine umdrehung um seine eigene achse
braucht er nur etwa zwei stunden
lockeres material rutscht durch die
fliehkraft zum äquator und gelangt somit
ins all teile des aktuellen werden also
bei kleinsten störungen sofort ins all
katapultiert was auch die
unregelmäßigkeit der schweizer erklärt
die nicht aus gas sondern ausschließlich
aus staub bestehen immer wenn ein großer
schwarm material verloren geht und
weggerissen wird werden die schweizer
also dichter die extreme umdrehung des
asteroiden kommt wohl durch den
ungleichen einfluss der
sonneneinstrahlung in der fachsprache
ist vom sogenannten jahr perfekt
rhede konkret gibt der asteroid die
wärme die er von der sonne aufgenommen
hat wieder ab doch das geschieht
unregelmäßig und so entsteht ein
winziges drehmoment doch das ganze
passiert über große zeiträume hinweg und
so entsteht dieser effekt der asteroid
wird in eine extrem starke rotation
versetzt und löst sich durch die
fliehkraft quasi auf dieses mysteriöse
phänomen beschäftigt forschungsteams
weltweit sodass kot im permanenten wie
sie verschiedener teleskope steht dazu
heißt es in einem bericht des
renommierten massachusetts institute of
technology mit
wir kennen eine million himmelskörper
zwischen mars und jupiter und vielleicht
20 im aktuellen gürtel sind aktiv also
ist das sehr selten doch mit der genauen
beobachtung des asteroiden gold
offenbarte sich jetzt eine weitere
riesige überraschung die wohl ebenfalls
auf die extreme rotation das zu ihnen
zurück zu führen ist
in einer aktuellen studie beschreibt das
forschungsteam von m
das überraschende verhalten genauer
demnach wechselte der us cent innerhalb
kürzester zeit seine farbe von rost
farben zu einem eher bläulichen farbton
das offenbaren die beobachtung die über
zwei nächte lang mit dem infrarot
teleskop auf hawaii durchgeführt wurden
dazu schreibt das autorenteam das war
eine sehr große überraschung wir haben
noch nie eine so dramatische änderung
wie diese in einer so kurzen zeit
gesehen vermutlich ist dies bedingt
durch eine staubschicht auf dem
asteroiden die innerhalb einiger
millionen jahre rot gefärbt wurde und
zwar durch das sonnenlicht doch die
extreme rotation hat jetzt offenbar
dafür gesorgt dass diese gealterte
staubschicht genau während der
beobachtung verloren gegangen ist ein
absoluter zufall und ein riesenglück für
die forschenden die darunter liegenden
schichten also die asteroiden oberfläche
aus gestein die sind bläulich gefärbt
das ganze ist eine premiere denn bislang
wurde eine verschiebung bei einem
asteroiden noch niemals in echtzeit
beobachtet doch durch die aktuellen
beobachtung ist nur eine sache ganz klar
nämlich dass sie sich auf keinen fall um
einen kometen handelt der aus staub und
eis besteht denn seine blaue oberfläche
enthält viele silikate die zeigen dass
es sich um einen typischen gesteins hast
du ihnen handle
das objekt auf kollisionskurs hier
anklicken anschauen und hyperraum tv
abonnieren mega kanal mit mega videos
immer lang und umfassend also bis dann
bleibt dran